Usually the older you get... the harder it
is to remember some things...
And we know a little bit about what goes wrong
in the aging brain.
But is this inevitable?
Everyone knows that one old person who is
90 but acts like they’re still young.
But HOW?
For answers, scientists are looking at people
known as superagers..and checkin’ out their
brains.
The term was coined by this guy.
Neurologist Dr. Marsel Mesulam
In this group there’s something that prevents
the loss of brain substance
we found actually over an 18 month period
the shrinkage in the brains of superagers
is less than average elderly”
Until this term was coined, researchers had
been focused on so called successful agers...
But what does that mean??
It’s not specific!
Successful aging could mean you’re physically
fit or just have a positive outlook - the
meaning was so broad it was hard to quantify
and compare research.
Now researchers are being more specific--
Superagers are people older than 80 with memories
just as good as someone in their 50s or 60s.
But we need to know: what makes their brains
different?
Were they bigger to start with?
Did they shrink but just not as fast?
Or did they actually get bigger over time?
Do genetics factor in?
What about personality?
Usually as humans age brains atrophy or shrink..
But researchers found the cortices of superager
brains are not as thin as expected.. and most
surprising... one part is thicker.
For reasons that we don’t understand there
is a little patch in the cingulate cortex
that seems to be thicker in superagers not
just compared to average elderly individuals
but compared to 50 and 60 year olds this is
pretty astounding
And within the thicker anterior cingulate
region of the cortex was another difference…
the superager brains had 3 to 5 times more
von Economo neurons…
These neurons are believed to help process
information faster and they’re linked to
higher social intelligence… animals like
whales and elephants and apes all have von
Economo neurons.
Beyond the anterior cingulate cortex… other
research shows 2 more areas that may be protected
in superager brains.. the midcingulate cortex
and the anterior insula were just as thick
as the younger control group … with no signs
of that thinning that usually comes with aging.
So… superager’s brains don’t seem to
atrophy as much as regular brains.
Though we don’t know why… but we haven’t
even talked about Alzheimer’s.
On the one hand...
A recent study found superager brains had
about 90% fewer neurofibrillary tangles -- twisted
protein fibers that block information transfer
-- and 90% fewer f -- protein clumps that
damage healthy brain cells -- both are markers
for Alzheimer’s disease.
On the other hand the latest research shows
some superager brains had major signs of Alzheimer’s
-- in the form of tangles and plaques -- but
they had no symptoms.
In this area, somehow, superagers defy the
odds!
Their brains could be more resistant to Alzheimer’s
or just more resilient.
There’s a lot we still don’t know.
So, what do you and I have to do to become
a superager?
Some researchers at Massachusetts General
suggest that working hard may work.
Both physically and mentally.
They admit it’s just a best guess theory.
But there is a lot of research suggesting
exercising the body may protect the brain…
But, when it comes to mental exercise… they
say simple brain games are not enough.
They believe you have to work until your brain
feels a little crappy.
You know that feeling when it hurts to think..
That’s a real physical condition!
A study in mice found that prolonged concentration
depletes glucose in the brain and may play
a role in that foggy feeling.
We obviously don’t have all the answers
or superagers wouldn’t be so super.
More research is needed.
What’s the internet doing to our memories…
making better .. worse..
Find out in this video.
Do you know any superagers?
your grandma or grandpa?
Tell us in the comments down below and don’t
forget to like and subscribe for seeker everyday.